[Applauso]
[Musica]
c'è una cosa che credo a cui non mi
abituerò mai nella vita e cioè lo
sguardo delle persone quando io vi dico
che mi occupo di astrofisica astrofisica
io ho cercato un paragone per far capire
cosa significa al giorno d'oggi essere
un astrofisico e la prima cosa che mi è
venuta in mente è un po essere un
esploratore da per questo che ho preso
in prestito il titolo dell'intervento di
oggi da un famoso film della di indiana
jones i predatori dell'arca perduta e
l'ho un po reinterpretare o chiamando lo
i predatori del fotone perduto perché
appunto il protagonista di questo
intervento oggi non sono io ma il
protagonista vero è appunto il fotone
ora magari molti di voi non sono degli
esperti non sanno che cos'è un fotone un
fotone praticamente è un quanto di luce
dal greco la parola fotone significa
proprio luce fosse quindi la luce che
noi vediamo luce visibile a una certa
sua energia abbastanza bassa diciamo noi
utilizziamo un termine tecnico per
definire l'energia di un fotone che le
elettronvolt insomma la luce che vediamo
all'uso di lampadine a luce visibile e
di qualche elettronvolt quindi una cosa
molto bassa ora però quello di cui
vorrei parlarvi oggi non è la luce
visibile ma è una radiazione molto
diversa molto più energetica quindi
questi pacchetti di energia questi
quanti sono molto più energetici e sono
i fotoni gamma della radiazione gamma
ora credo che nell'immaginazione comune
quando si sente parlare di radiazioni
gamma si pensi quasi sempre a hulk un
essere mostruoso che è stato appunto
trasformato perché è stato esposto alla
radiazione gamma ora è un ottimo
paragone anche questo anche per diciamo
a livello scientifico perché dove
vengono prodotti questi questa
radiazione gamma
nell'universo viene prodotta proprio
dove ci sono le sorgenti più
catastrofiche più violente più mostruose
quindi da lì possiamo dire che è
decisamente un buon paragone ora però
com'è che noi stessi non ci trasformiamo
ogni giorno in hulk colpiti da questa
radiazione gamma e noi abbiamo una
protezione naturale che ci protegge ogni
giorno ovvero la nostra atmosfera
noi siamo protetti della nostra
atmosfera cosa hanno fatto quindi i
fisici astrofisici per dire come posso
studiare questa radiazione gamma hanno
deciso di andare oltre l'atmosfera oggi
si è parlato di nuvole
ecco noi con altri strumenti andiamo
oltre le nuvole oltre l'atmosfera e ci
spostiamo nello spazio questa è
un'immagine del satellite nasa per cui
appunto lavoro anch'io un progetto nasa
in collaborazione con le agenzie
spaziali italiane e francesi tedesca
giapponese svedese che è in orbita
attorno alla terra a circa 550
chilometri di altezza e orbita attorno
alla terra circa in un'ora e mezza
costantemente e appunto è il nostro
satellite per poter catturare per poter
andare a caccia di questi di questi
fotoni ora è in orbita dal 2008 quindi
l'anno prossimo festeggeremo dieci anni
dal lancio di questo satellite in dieci
anni di fotoni ne abbiamo visti parecchi
in aprile abbiamo avuto una sorta
diciamo di anniversario perché abbiamo
rivelato il miliardesimo fotone ecco
diciamo sono veramente grossi come
numeri ma com'è che noi comunichiamo
appunto con questo con questo satellite
chiaramente noi prendiamo i dati
riceviamo a terra
però proprio diciamo nella vita di tutti
i giorni il modo migliore per comunicare
con questo satellite sono proprio i
nostri cellulari
ovviamente noi abbiamo dei programmi
stavate sul cellulare che ci permettono
di ricevere proprio degli sms classici
ms ms me ne è arrivato uno o pochi
minuti fa
che mi diceva il satellite ha registrato
diciamo un po di fotoni che sono
arrivati tutti insieme
ecco questo evento noi lo chiamiamo un
lampo di raggi gamma quando arriva un
insieme di fotoni tutti nello stesso
momento e in un tempo molto breve
pensate che quello che è arrivato pochi
minuti fa in un evento talmente breve
che non è durato nemmeno due secondi
cioè due secondi proprio è un tempo
veramente ridicolo
quanta energia abbiamo misurato con
questo strumento che appunto è costruito
appositamente per catturare e fare
diciamo interagire il fotone all'interno
e misurarne l'energia bene in un secondo
e mezzo noi abbiamo registrato un
energia che pari a quella che il sole
emette in tutta la sua vita in tutto il
suo ciclo di vita
quindi immaginatevi di quanto stiamo
parlando bene questo lampo di raggi
gamma appunto breve ne abbiamo potuto
misurare l'energia ma la domanda
classica adesso è da dove arriva da dove
viene che cos'è di cosa si tratta bene
allora facciamo un viaggio a ritroso
cerchiamo di capire da dove arriva
questo riverivano questi fotoni di
estrema energia
ora per capire come si fa ad andare
diciamo in giro per lo spazio bisogna un
attimo capire le distanze e le
tempistiche
se voi pensate che quando guardiamo per
esempio la luce del sole
noi praticamente stiamo guardando una
sorta di immagine scattata qualche
minuto prima ora noi rispetto al nostro
sole siamo a circa 150 milioni di
chilometri così per avere un'idea vaga e
la luce che ha una velocità finita
quindi il fotone della luce ci mette 8
minuti ad arrivare fino a noi
questo significa che quando noi
guardiamo la luce del sole in realtà
vediamo la luce che è partita 8 minuti
fa allo stesso modo quando il nostro
satellite registra un fotone gamma preso
a punto le gamma che arriva
probabilmente da molto lontano e quindi
è partito tantissimo tempo fa
quanto
tempo fa e questo quello che cerchiamo
di andare a spiegare allora sicuramente
non è arrivato dal nostro sistema solare
quindi dobbiamo parlare di distanze
enormi e sicuramente non è nemmeno
arrivato dalla nostra galassia la nostra
galassia altro non è che un insieme
diciamo di tanti sistemi solari di tante
stelle come il nostro sole più grandi
più piccole ce n'è veramente tantissime
è arrivati a questo punto bisogna
trovare diciamo un'altra unità di misura
per spiegare quanto siano grandi queste
distanze
pensate che la galassia e larga 100 mila
anni luce l'anno luce è proprio unità di
misura per diciamo per descrivere una
distanza che cioè una distanza percorsa
dalla luce in un anno quindi
immaginatevi di quanti migliaia di
miliardi di km
stiamo parlando ecco questi fotoni di
cui vi ho parlato questo lampo gamma
però non arriva neanche da qua dobbiamo
spostarci quindi non a 100 mila anni
luce ma neanche a milioni di anni luce
dobbiamo arrivare ai miliardi di anni
luce a qualche miliardo significa che la
luce che noi abbiamo appena registrato è
partita qualche miliardo di anni fa e
quindi è e cosa c'è in questo posto
lontanissimo
probabilmente è successo qualcosa così è
successo un evento come vi odio tarizzo
mostruoso catastrofico cosa vedete qua
vedete due oggetti potremmo dire due
stelle si sono probabilmente sono due
stelle dell'universo ci sono moltissime
stelle di da.dd varie dimensioni e
spesso non si trovano come il nostro
sole che appunto è una stella solitaria
una stella single
no si trovano spesso in coppia circa il
50 per cento dei dei sistemi stellari
sono sistemi detti binari
ecco questo è un caso di sistema binario
che improvvisamente diciamo con leader
come mai queste due stelle in
particolare che sono diciamo raffigurate
qui
artisticamente sono due stelle che sono
in qualche modo un po paragonabili al
nostro sole perché come dimensioni
diciamo come massa come la massa
racchiusa in questa stella sono
paragonabili magari sono grandi quanto
una due masse solari però immaginatevi
di prendere la massa del sole che è
grande un milione e mezzo di chilometri
quindi è enorme e mettere tutta questa
massa nella dimensione di pochi decine
di chilometri come se voi mettete la
dimensione tutta la massa del nostro
sole dentro il diametro della città di
taranto per esempio ecco immaginatevi
quanto sono dense queste stelle hanno
una densità tale che è praticamente una
densità paragonabile all'atomo la
densità atomica e per queste vengono
chiamate stelle di neutroni
ora cosa succede queste stelle
praticamente cominciano una sorta di
danza per che orbitano un accanto una
vicino all'altra sono legate dalla
gravità e cominciano ruotare in pratica
sis avviene quello che può essere
definito un una danza cosmica ci sono
queste forze fra le due stelle che
attraggono sempre di più con l'aumentare
diciamo col diminuire delle delle
distanze le due le due stelle diventano
sempre più veloci la velocità di
rotazione è sempre più forte
finché le due stelle non collidono
quando collidono cosa succede si forma
una altra stella un altro oggetto che è
ancora più denso dei precedenti potrebbe
essere un buco nero magari qualcuno di
voi ne ha già sentito parlare
una stella che ancora più densa e
talmente densa che cattura anche la luce
stessa da lì appunto il nome buco nero
quello che forse non avete notato perché
il video è stato molto molto veloce è
che a un certo punto durante questa
collisione c'è stata l'espulsione come
di due getti di materia
ecco quando queste due stelle
compatte collidono sia tutti si sono
come dei meccanismi che stiamo ancora
studiando e cercando di capire per cui
l'amat e una parte della materia di
queste due stelle viene espulsa in
qualche cosa che bene o male ci ricorda
un po il faro per esempio la luce del
farr di una lanterna no e quindi questa
danza che ha da cui abbiamo appena
assistito crea queste lanterne cosmiche
quindi cosa abbiamo fatto noi sul nostro
satellite
eravamo lì in ascolto e siamo stati
colpiti da uno di questi eventi da
qualche parte nell'universo miliardi di
chilometri c'è stato un evento del
genere in cui queste due stelle si sono
fuse e hanno mandato questo impulso che
ricordiamo c'era un impulso brevissimo
vi ho detto di un secondo e noi eravamo
appunto pronti a catturarlo
da lì ancora un po l'espressione
dell'esploratore che cattura il fotone
ecco io vorrei concludere con un con un
altro tipo di segnale che potrebbe anche
diciamo essere paragonato a questo noi
eri abbiamo festeggiato un altro
importante anniversario nella comunità
scientifica scientifica ovvero due anni
dalla rivelazione di un altro tipo di
segnale non un segnale elettromagnetico
come appunto i fotoni ma un segnale
gravitazionale un'onda gravitazionale e
da cosa è nata quest'onda gravitazionale
è nata proprio da un balletto cosmico
diciamo un po come quello che avete
visto nel video precedente erano diversi
gli oggetti di partenza erano più grossi
aveva una densità maggiore erano
probabilmente dei buchi neri che si sono
appunto fusi e non hanno però diciamo
come in questo caso mandato un getto una
lanterna ma hanno mandato una sorta di
vibrazione nello spazio tempo che noi
siamo stati in grado di rilevare sulla
terra con delle tecniche estremamente
difficili giusto per farvi capire quanto
è difficile rilevare una un segnale
spazio temporale di quel genere potete
immaginarvi di essere in un lago di
montagna molto grande con
una superficie liscissima e qualcuno
dall'altra parte sulla riva
completamente opposta butta in acqua un
sassolino minuscolo e voi che siete
tutto dall'altra parte dovete cercare di
capire di percepire come sulla
superficie si sia diciamo protratta
questa questo segnale quindi una cosa
difficilissima che però al giorno d'oggi
riusciamo a fare quindi per concludere
sono tanti anni ormai che diciamo una
trentina d'anni che noi scienziati siamo
riusciti appunto a essere sempre in
allerta per capire da dove arrivano
questi segnali questi fotoni ed è appena
da un paio d'anni che siamo non solo in
allert diciamo visiva ma siamo anche in
ascolto per sentire questi segnali
gravitazionali quindi alla fine di
questo viaggio la cosa che vorrei
appunto comunicarvi è che noi
esploratori noi astrofisici siamo sempre
sempre in ascolto ogni giorno siamo
sempre in allerta per captare questi
segnali che quando giungono a noi da
miliardi di anni di distanza ci
insegnano qualcosa sulle leggi che
creano il nostro universo
[Applauso]